if we look at cloud and i'm only talking
about cloud i'm not talking about other
types
of sas pass and is cloud
consumption alone is the market of over
350 billion dollars
and it's estimated to be over 600
billion dollars
by the end of 2021 so it's a huge huge
market and we kind of lie
in between um both of these markets
uh which is both cyber and cloud
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
we are going to talk about insurance for
the cloud for the digital world
meet neta rosie co-founder and cto of
parametrics insurance
neta was born and raised in the san
francisco bay area silicon valley
and moved to israel to enlist in the idf
as a lone soldier
and then moved back to the us to work as
a software engineer and team lead
what grounded her in as well was meeting
the now co-founders of parametrics
the company's mission is to ensure that
companies with mission critical services
in the cloud
are fully protected from the financial
damages of downtime caused by sas
pass and last such as cloud ecommerce
payments crm
and cdn service providers neda rosie
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
great doing great good to be here i
i'm i'm so ecstatic that you're here and
i'm already a little bit stressed
because 20 minutes are not going to be
nearly enough time for me to
dive into all the topics that i want to
dive into because both you're upbringing
in
california moving to israel as a lone
soldier to enlist
a software engineer and then co-founding
and being cto
of a wonderful company that is is doing
something that we all
you know understand in different
contexts this world of insurance
but doing it for you know sas products
and cyber security and
you know it's things that you know
didn't exist 20 30 years ago and so i'm
excited to
dive into all of those topics but before
i do all that take me all the way back
to
you're moving to israel you're coming to
enlist as a lone soldier
what's going on over there
yeah why did i do it um yeah i
am my family is from israel
um i i felt like that was the right
thing to do
so i uh you know came joined uh the idf
and enlisted as
as a lone soldier and uh and the rest is
history
but it's not it's that simple right
because you you grew up in in the united
states and
you know i went through an american
system and now i go to an american
college it's not that easy to
all of a sudden you know change
locations and put on a uniform
in a different language in a different
atmosphere right oh yeah it's not easy
um you know all my friends uh
continued on to college i went to um
regular public school there wasn't um
a community around me that that went to
uh
the idf um i was definitely uh the
oddball
out uh but i think everything i do i
kind of do differently so it's
um it's quite normal for me
and and how has engineering been a part
of your life
were you always curious about technology
and engineering or is this something
from the military where did it all begin
for you
yeah it started way before i've always
been technological
my mom actually uh chose a technological
career path as well
so um i think i definitely had a kind of
a head start through her
um and and it's just always been there
throughout
you know high school and even before
that right and so you're
you're you're you have various positions
software engineer
and others and now you're cto
of parametrics insurance and it's a
different type of insurance like i
mentioned
tell me a little bit even before you
talk about what it is
you're you're creating this company with
some of the most amazing entrepreneurs
i believe the former founder and ceo of
tenbis is one of them
what is you know how do you how do you
get together and decide to form a
company
yeah so um i definitely have an
an amazing team uh beside me and and
i can speak a little bit about my my
co-founders
they actually everyone except for me is
an experienced entrepreneur so this is
their
uh second startup including as you
mentioned uh uh
co-founder and chairman uh tamir who
founded tenbis
um for those of you who don't know it's
uh it's
probably the largest e-commerce uh uh
website in in israel
um with food delivery and kind of the
status of high tech i think
in in the tel aviv uh culture um and
in addition to that um our ceo and
co-founder jonathan hudsor
uh who had a uh he was cto and
co-founder of a startup that did
a 3d modeling for construction sites and
they still they're bootstrapped they're
still around they're actually doing
amazing
um and ori our our ceo
uh she previously had a um
eco water solutions uh startup that also
uh merged into
um one of the largest in in israel and
at that point we kind of
took her out so um yeah i have an
amazing team
we met through some personal connections
um and and got together and we just had
this amazing click
uh we were playing around with with some
ideas and uh you know
insurance is such a such a and it's
such an amazing industry actually um
it's
a huge industry there's so much
innovation to be done
and um kind of there's amazing partners
in the insurance industry and they're
just thirsty for innovation and for
partnering together
was it stressful at all to start a
company
with serial entrepreneurs and
i mean i would be i would be a little
nervous i have to say
um yeah maybe a bit uh but but i think
this is kind of always
been my path um like you know we spoke
about earlier it's
i do things differently um and so this
was
this was always kind of where where it
was leading to
um and uh there's just so much to learn
from them you know there's so many
mistakes that they have
um avoided for us uh based on past
experience and it
it it really speaks for itself right so
so cto are you know talking about going
sometimes against the grain and
you know it's not you know i don't think
needs to be an elephant in the room
there are not many female ctos
let alone in such a technical and
regulatory business
and and you know there needs to be many
many more and and
you know i'm sure that you're also an
inspiration for many young women out
there but
nevertheless a female cto of him
of a upcoming insurance company in the
tech space and you're doing insurance
not the traditional home insurance and
you know physical product
it's a different type tell me a little
bit about parametrics and what you're
doing there
yeah so um at parametrics
uh so maybe we can we can backtrack just
a little bit
um parametrics is is the startup that
creates a downtime insurance for sas
pass and is
uh downtime so that can be cloud
computing payment systems crms
web hosting isp cdns you name it any
type of infrastructure that
businesses build themselves up on today
and
when downtime happens on these pieces of
their infrastructure
they experience downtime as well and
they incur the losses
even though the downtime wasn't their
own fault so in that we've actually be
been able to identify this uh protection
gap that existed in the insurance market
and in this pain point that companies
are feeling and create this amazing
product around it
now what powers that is technology and
it
it's the reason why this insurance
hasn't um
existed before because the technology
hasn't been created to be able to
empower it
and for us what it allows to do is to
eliminate the claims process
so our insurance doesn't have a claims
process
um the claims process in insurance was
designed
in order for the insured to prove what
happened
during the incident so to prove their
losses to prove
um you know when it happened how it
happened to kind of
list out the incident where if you're
able to monitor that
and to know exactly what happened
throughout the incident
there's actually no need for for a
claims process
um and so that's what what we do that's
what i focus on which is the the
technology aspect of
of the company we build really really
robust monitoring systems that monitor
sas pass and yas
globally so we know exactly what's
happening at any given time
and there's no need for our customers to
submit a claim
so you're you know on one hand you're
saying that yes technology
you know is a factor in the fact that we
need we you need to build great
technology in order to be able to
actually identify
what's happening there but this also
just wasn't an issue
30 years ago right i mean literally it
wasn't an issue back when
and so you know we're talking about you
know when homes were starting to be
built in the world
i'm sure it took a few good hundred
years until they figured out oh we can
sell insurance and
and and do this give and take here and
i'm you know it's amazing to me as a
young entrepreneur
seeing you know how the world is moving
and how you know and a startup can now
come up and say you know what we're
identifying a gap we can create a whole
new market
and and potentially be a market leader
for that now how do you identify though
the the the you know the the costs that
are incurred
so i'm thinking to myself you know if i
run a business and i have downtime
how do i translate that to you know
tangible losses
that i would then need to you know come
be compensated for
yeah so um you would be surprised how
much
uh you know a business knows exactly how
much downtime costs them they can
really specify you know it can be a
matter of the the direct revenue loss it
can be recovery expenses
um it can be a intangible cost like
brand or
sla liability to their own customers
which is a huge huge huge cost
um even if downtime is not their own
fault so in most cases they actually
know how to
calculate how much downtime costs them
and when um
but since we have uh you know
we have seen many many cases of downtime
and how it affects
companies we actually know how to
calculate it so um
we will give uh you know an estimation
of loss and how much we think the
business
uh and loses per hour based on other
businesses
similar to it based on the type of
business the industry
uh their revenue things of that sort um
and then they can adjust that if they
see the number
any differently than we do right so just
like when you're
giving insurance for a trip or a home or
anything like that when
you say okay how much is the home worth
and your premium
is based on that i'm guessing here
similarly a premium would be based on
you know how you know an agreement that
you make with the businesses
over what is a downtime worth per for
example per hour right
yeah exactly do companies understand
this
when you come to a sas company and you
say we want to provide insurance for you
do they get what you're talking about oh
yeah
oh yeah companies have experienced
downtime and
up until now there really wasn't um a
financial solution
for it so they they have definitely felt
the pain
um they know exactly what we're speaking
about and there's actually a lot of
demand
um not even not only that but also um
their brokers and kind of their um
the people that deal with the risk of
the company um
have been hearing from their own
customers kind of the
the need for this type of insurance and
it just hasn't existed up until today
right and i'm guessing that you know
these companies that you approach
you know i'm you know i've never thought
of this i have to say and i'm from the
insurance space right now
and i haven't stopped to think wow it
makes perfect sense and especially
you know my mom is dealing a lot with
globalization and cyber security from a
regulatory perspective
and i'm saying like yes it's so obvious
because it's not just downtime because
of an error
but you know i want to be insured if if
there's a cyber security attack that
causes you know my own technology to
have downtime
still not necessarily my fault and and i
want to be insured for that so it makes
perfect sense what is what has been a
struggle here what has been a challenge
you know on this journey that you're on
[Music]
um so i mean that that again i turned to
my uh
to my co-founders where um they don't
see challenges they've seen so many
challenges
uh over their career where they're just
not um
you know they're not budged uh by
challenges i will say the insurance
industry um
is highly regulated regulated which is
something to take into consideration um
there is regulation that you have to go
through and licensing and all things of
that sort
um that but but that's not a challenge
you know
um and and i just do wanna do wanna go
back to
uh the point that you made about cyber
um
where cyber insurance is is also a
market in the insurance industry
um where cyber insurance is the market
that's evaluated
at uh over nine billion dollars and it's
growing almost 30
a year but if we look at cloud and i'm
only talking about cloud i'm not talking
about other types
of sas pass and is um cloud
consumption alone is the market of over
350 billion dollars
and it's estimated to be over 600
billion dollars
by the end of 2021 so it's a huge huge
market and we kind of lie
in between um both of these markets
which is both cyber and cloud um
and it's it's it's really growing very
fast
i mean both of those are amazing news
because regardless you know
that the transition is is not that great
once you diluted to saying
we want we we know how to identify your
costs
on downtime there could be a variety of
reasons why you may have downtime you
know potentially
an employee can can push a bug to
production
i've done that a few times and and cause
downtime for various organizations
and you know that downtime costs and and
it costs a lot sometimes like
like you're saying here and i'm assuming
that specifically what you're referring
to in the technology sphere is
your ability to to remove the claims
process which i'm sure
while i haven't find claims myself i'm
sure that it's a really cumbersome
process
that really is the innovative part
beyond the fact that you're entering
into a really
innovative market with an innovative
approach right
yeah absolutely um claims are one of the
biggest pain points in the insurance
market
i think that's no surprise to anyone um
it's
it's just something that you know you
can try and improve it as much as you
can
but if you're able to just get rid of it
that's the best way to go
now what what excites you really about
what you're doing no
is it is it the entrepreneurial journey
is it the business the technology the
people
what is it oh gosh it's all of the above
um it really it's it's just being a part
of change
um being being a part of change working
with amazing people
um and and kind of moving towards this
vision that we have as a company
and so and when you when no one asks
this question do you think more about
the day to day
more about the marathon like how how do
you approach
you know this excitement how far ahead
are you are you living in
at any given moment um i think it
depends when you ask
so um i'd say both um
as as a co-founder um i'm i'm
living in in the vision of the company
but you know as as my position as cto
i'm also living in the present um and
and you know we
we need to execute uh in order to be
able to reach that
that joint vision that we have i love it
neta are you ready for a few uh fun yet
a little weird few weird questions i
should say
yeah sure let's go for it all right
let's do it we'll start off easy
uh one or more of your favorite subject
in
subjects in school but only k to 12.
um okay i mean i think i think that's
easy
um you know computer science is probably
the main one how young did you start in
computer science
um i think it was towards the end of
middle school we had the opportunity to
to start yeah
start learning i think it was i think it
was java back then
intro that's that's amazing my first
experience was i believe in 11th grade
and uh i i wish i had opportunities like
that in middle school
that's really phenomenal one of your
role models or somebody that
inspires you on on a regular basis
um you've probably heard this a million
times but i
i'll probably say my mom um and that's
because she
she took such a technological career
path that i think
inspired me and and kind of led me on on
mine as well
right and so did you grow up with
sort of this engineering mindset in the
house where you did she helped you know
motivate you to go into that or
was it just more of a comfort knowing
that you know you can do it
yeah i think it's just you know you can
do it um and and we've always had
technology around the house so it was
just very
natural um you know i
i i just looked up to her it wasn't uh
she didn't she never pushed me to it or
anything of that sort
i love that intrinsic inspiration and
neta
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself and and why
those three
um okay um i think passionate
um passionate
passion is something that i i think any
entrepreneur has
uh it's it's something you have to have
in order to succeed
um i'm excited i'm
i'm excited again for for what we're
doing and always learning
you just cannot stop learning
are there some things that you looking
back on your journey now
you know whether it is in high school or
the idea for later on
that you're that you know some merely
big ideas that you would take with you
back then some things and perhaps not
that didn't know and you know i as a
young entrepreneur i always think about
okay what what are some things
10 years from now i'll say wow i wish i
knew
this or i had this perspective are there
some things that you're observing now
that you're
you know you know co-founder of a
company and you're looking back
they're saying wow this is something
that i that i only experience
could have taught me
um i i think just
being brave enough to to have those
experiences
you know to to emerge out of that box
that kind of society puts us in and do
things differently
yeah definitely neta today thank you
very very much
best of luck with paramedics insurance
uh it sounds like a
both a great mission a great market
great timing and it sounds like a
phenomenal team
and so i i i wish you best of luck and
thank you for taking the time to come on
the show i know how busy you are thank
you
thank you i appreciate your time